no i don't i don't think that the growth
of nonprofits and specifically
environmental nonprofits has diluted
surfrider foundation at all matter fact
I love having more help anywhere we can
get it the more the merrier it's great I
think what is changing as I mentioned a
while ago was a was everything happened
in the 90s all the technology we can now
in about 14 hours send 10,000 emails to
government Schwarzenegger on an issue we
can send 20,000 emails to people in
Chile I mean we can tap people we can
talk face to face all over the world
using skype we do those things are
radically shifting the toolset the
capabilities and the power that is at
the edge of the network of our culture
so all of a sudden you don't have to be
Rupert Murdoch buying the wall street
journal to have your hand on the
joystick you can be 10,000 people in
Argentina you can do this a lot of
different ways as long as you understand
and implement technology one of my
favorite things that just came out was a
$99 video player that records on flash
the size of a cell phone that gave them
away as freebies at this conference that
I'm at right now very very powerful tool
no I think something has shifted in the
last 12 months which is radically
different than it was before it used to
be that business was bad government was
slow NGO dash and virus were good
they're all the smart people were etc in
anything with a corporate brand was
essentially bad and what has happened in
the last 12 months is that governments
are still slow I think they'll always be
slow business has flipped from one of
their emotions to the other emotion and
they only have two emotions and the one
emotion that they were in was fear they
didn't understand the environment they
didn't understand the cost of all these
things and they do now so you have Jim
Rogers CEO of Duke Energy amazing guy
making amazing statements Walmart is
making amazing strides DuPont making
amazing strides so now they flipped over
to their other convenient emotion which
is greed business has the capital they
have the reach they have the
infrastructure they have the
distribution channel to consumers
business will drive the green movement
it's also what Thomas Friedman saying
and as new kind of green is the new red
white and blue people are saying green
is the new gold etc and it's not as
simple as that businesses are cashing in
that's not the message at all businesses
will cash in regardless the point is
that the globe is in a crisis mode it's
redlining and businesses cannot sustain
their model unless they adapt and they
are much quicker to adapt than a
government which we're seeing all over
the world
you